ça n'empêche que ce micro l'un d'eux
permet quelque chose on va pas être
corps étaient enterrés et j'étais passé
en ensuite dans un concours de thérèse
qui s'affaisse en 80 secondes encore
connue prendre feu et l'a arrêté ainsi
de perturber inscrits seront présents
des roues 13 ans 3,50
on va essayer à la ferme a préparé un
trou c'était pas mal expérience
intéressante mais en tout cas
l'expérience qu'ils pensent que je suis
un peu d'accord
l'objectif d'aujourd'hui parce que j'ai
le temps d'un petit peu le temps de vous
raconter mon histoire une histoire qui
est aussi la vôtre
pourquoi parce que je vais parler du
territoire écrit tellement serré cas où
ce concept n'a égalisé
j'ai bien visé par la parole
je dirais les formations académiques du
cari zélande et nos espaces est réservé
aux médias etc
mais il a quand même pris de l'ampleur
avec le temps pourquoi justement nous
parce que je vais commencer par cette
première expérience qui est la suivante
le territoire des morts reeves rire cet
amour rives les territoires au pluriel
moi je vous dis ça ce que je vous
raconte des petites histoires que peu de
personnes la plupart donc on est des
gens m'envoient supporter moi cette
histoire vient d'une femme un jour dans
la forêt alors que
les directs les animaux tous les espaces
riches et on vivait 30 membres en
essence mr jour y avait un feu cette
histoire de colibri justement qui est
extrêmement importante à partager un
jour le connaître un jour la forêt
religieux bien quand elle a pris feu
tout le monde peut commencer à partir ce
qu'on fait d'habitude quand il ya un
problème on part on part on quitte le
problème n'est ce pas eh bien tous les
animaux commencerait à partir de
maintenant il y avait quand même un
colibri qui a comme un petit oiseau
minuscule a commencé à prendre
à travers ça aux mecs naulleau quelques
petites photos et d'années qui fait le
va et vient pour justement et se veut
briller important il revient à toutes
nos trois on lui dit et ça va mal c'est
parce que c'est pas avec ça avec ce
petit but d'autres si tu vas tu
le feu nature bien coller privé de banc
je le sais mais je fais ma part faisant
autre part je pense que c'est aussi
d'autres obligations aujourd'hui de
partager ces expériences là parce que
c'était je dirais expérience j'ai vécu
hier du territoire commencé il ya il ya
maintenant dix ans quand j'ai conçu par
alain starks a fait l'économie des
territoires et du porno ça apprend des
choses de liqueur le bicentaire comment
sont un petit peu saluer les flux cette
musique née bis c'est donc qu'ils
voulaient côté gestion comme ça q des
pulls et les marchandises comment
comment on anime le territoire entités
associées quels sont les différents
types de territoires ont pas est de la
terreur mais ne la refera
je suis allé faire une thèse en
géographie et rage y compris des
réalités des rides territoire en faisant
du terrain là j'ai dormi plusieurs
questions plusieurs prennent aux belges
puis à ses clients
par la suite il
j'ai perdu le temps avec d'autres amis
chercheurs j'ai pu mettre en place un
club que l'on pourrait changer justement
de leur réflexion pour échanger des
problématiques pas seulement des
territoires mais des problématiques qui
font débat on sait qu'ils sont un petit
peu dans beit tombé dans l'oubli
par la force des choses et bien c'est
telle expérience très intéressante nous
a faits m'ont traîné plusieurs paradoxes
où je citerai quelques paradoxes que
j'ai appelé par à notre fondateur qui
sont ils demandent une question du
territoire
premier paradoxe auquel nous faisons
nous le faisons sur souvent face celui
justement que dans nos positions hurle
un territoire donné
c'est à dire espionner traditional sv
train expo d'élise m'en fais partie ce
qu'on fait partie
nous risquons d'être algérienne moderne
sur cette question quand on est arrivé
on verra bien sûr toujours y ce que est
ce qu'on est vraiment ce qu'on révise
ses spreads est vraiment cette
expérience des moments spirituels en
tenant compte que ce sont toujours des
journaux des elfes qui y vivent qu'on
nous reconnaisse pas très civilisée très
je dirais très moderne et puis nous et
c'est pas facile parce qu'elle voulait
respecter sinon nos habitudes nos notre
vie quotidienne
est ce qu'elle est prise dans le dans le
sens où la modernité les transhumances
essence et un premier paradoxe où kate
ne faisons donc le temps fasse dans leur
territoire
deuxième paradoxe est celui du
conjoncturel que structurel
nous ouvrons nos politiques publiques
vous avez vous remarqué que quand il ya
un problème qu'il arrive on vient et
puis on injecte des filets le ce dans le
genre dans une politique publique parce
qu'il ya un problème de l'agriculture
un problème de ces fameux on doit faire
un petit peu émergé nouvelle compilation
entrepreneurs étudiants des pierres on
va mettre des enfants et puis on va
donner de l'argent
ça c'est pour vous un problème quand
jour d'urée et qui est au fond un
problème comme les fonds structurels
fonds dans des structures d'aujourd'hui
où l'esprit d'entreprendre de l'esprit
de leadership avant quatre essais de
jerez le recouvrement du jour ce
problème d'exercice vis-à-vis de ce col
roulé nous voulons avoir à tout prix les
entrepreneurs jeunes et donc nous allons
leur donner des marges en dépit yvan
arrivé il ya dix estiment sans bien sûr
une lecture
de nos projets et ce qu'il réalise
justement ce que nous voulons être ce
que nous voulons faire ce qu'on voulait
devenir un autre aspect important d'y
devenir ce à celui de troisième paradoxe
sectorielle versus territoriales je
parle c'est plus intéressant à mon sens
nos politiques pour quoi il s'agit cette
dernière vous avez entendu parler d'eux
les plants offerts et sa femme dans le
monde génération verte 2022 min 30 20 30
il est fermement rappelé or-azur des
millions des millions de touristes à
duties et puis d'autres aussi se
baladent quelque part et belle chance on
entend beaucoup de choses qui se font
très souvent intéressants en règle des
images mais au fond dans les territoires
qu'est ce que nous avons fait pour ce
lundi et dans le trafic
pour ce tour élite maillard en donne
plus d'aisé dire aux gens que vous êtes
de calais certains soldats
on aime finir fanny projet s'ajoute
étudie avec un dunga n'y en ait pas je
le dis très gratifiant tendue c'est pas
pour tout le monde évidemment
mais bien sûr cette instance aujourd'hui
à notre territoire appartenant jury
provincial commencé à disparaître si tu
dis à quelqu'un je n'aime ça dérange et
on dira monsieur je ne veux pas dire que
vous êtes du souss tu passeras ressource
essentielle du ternaire et de massage ou
la vidalie c'est l'appartenance de
province et commencent à disparaître
bien sûr vous allez peut-être que de
s'intéresser très relatif c'est pareil
mais c'est par des propos moi je parle
de cette expérience que j'ai pu faire
avec l'ensemble du territoire et cela
révèle beaucoup de choses c'est normal
parce qu en tout cas nos bassins un
territoire complètement urban
complètement
des territoires et pas aujourd'hui la
preuve c'est la région vi nations
avancées accomplies qui montre que le
sort de terre nous allons alerter
c'est notre lutte est plus avancée quand
on parle de danger on parle de tanger
tétouan et puis tout le bassin qui va
avec
quand on parle de fasciner c'est tout le
bassin c'était des métropolitains du
seuil est à comparer du souss de grands
artisans ni les comptes a gagné et c'est
la même chose pour mes autres
territoires
je te dirais que aujourd'hui cette
confrontation ce paradoxe
existe toujours il doit encore continuer
à qui celles-ci parce que no1 si tu
commence à réfléchir sur ce qu'est ce
que nous voulons être c'est ce que j'ai
appelé cette intégration nous qui semble
cependant l'autorité
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour une victoire
et c'est un vent avait des quelque chose
très importante
3 4e femme adore ce titre universalité
et de l'identité
il existe aujourd'hui de dire à
quelqu'un juge demande de lui dire que
tu dois faire de telles choses dans ma
vie madame nous parce que la famille
faisait ça elle jeune mais avant de dire
je garde ça qu'on va bien on pourrait
même ça et on accepte aujourd'hui c'est
pas parce qu'on est dans des bars à 2016
- dont les manoeuvres densité du québec
mais calme tendu est encore les cheveux
est injuste je dirais de pouvoirs et des
contre-pouvoirs notamment justement
cette personne était vif importante
femme a déclaré rodrigues noah est ce
que voulant un territoire en verre sur
les autres et puis capable justement
l'amorcé d'une nouvelle idée nouvelle
création de vous fait je dirais de
nouvelles possibilités telles puisque
nous cherchant justement affaires de
certains de ses fans de 7,1 catégorie
justement sur confessions échanges sont
calmes allemands des belges est pétri la
valeur ajoutée mais on n'a jamais pensé
aussi à ce sera dommage était importante
et social et nous nous reverrons huit
ans un phénomène extrêmement important
qui justement il y a eu nos politiques
au quai d'en face
même si je j'ai une casquette
aujourd'hui d'un quart d'heure à
l'aménagement du territoire mais du
casque est chercheur qui est plus
importante que celle d'un cadre
fonctionnel aujourd'hui vous avez
certainement entendu que tout le monde
parle justement des inégalités sociales
et spatiales que la région en raison de
des pierres de diffa n'est pas comme
celle de la région de rabat salé témara
que l'accès par exemple l'accès aux
bibliothèques par exemple dans la ville
de rabat dont le grand gaza et pas comme
celle ci on n'est donc pas chez dia
si on est dans le champ de la place abri
vous voulez et bien c'est cela crée une
première la première à notre paradoxe
celui justement de la contrée ensemble
ces différents fermée aujourd'hui
cette inégalité seller géographique mais
ne vont pas être surtout son cher
c'était aujourd'hui je voudrais macarena
unanime qui est dans le billet
disponible non qui doit être disponible
dans toutes les régions du royaume
qu'elle soit aujourd'hui dans un
disparités aussi qu'elles sont accès aux
services de base
on savait qu'il ya encore des
territoires qui font sans aucun problème
de 2,2 richesse raisons de l'échec
24 mai nous lé pas très compliqué dans
secret sont très complexes et cassis
beaucoup de temps de recul c'est qu'on
dit toujours que on a la marsa
après j'ai vu pas grave je pense en tout
cas cette question territoriale moment
dire que il faut reprendre beaucoup plus
de recul par rapport à ce qu'on fait
alors parce qu'on ne voulant être dansée
par malaga sont des disparités très
importantes
il ya une autre question à d'autres
paradoxe où je voudrais ajouter ceux qui
te l'urbain et le rural chez quel moment
où on pourrait dire que nous appartenons
à un ordre brad et quand je veux dire
que j'appartiens ma mère
visage en dessous ce qui s'appelle
mézague et qui n'a rien fait et qui
campent et nos mères nos complètement de
la veille du monde sur balles
même si j mondiale j'ai gardé cette
affiliation à la patience et à ses
assassins territoire est ce que
j'appelle les territoires du vécu et
puis j'ai grandi de par ses larges et
plus acquérir sa croissance interne j'ai
pu connaître des professeurs j'ai pu
connaître dans un autre espace du savoir
tous les espaces de savoir faire c'est
ce que j'appelle des territoires de
connaissances se passent à la loupe les
territoires du vécu ou territoires
connaissance était vraiment importante
parce que c'est avec ça qu'on ne peut
rien justement avancer notre manière de
voir les gens ont des ressorts
classiques jeux aujourd'hui je veux
interpeller
mon profil je dis que ce passage en tant
qu'économie ce territoire vers un autre
esprit et celui de philosophie auteur de
votre tournée des territoires c'est très
importante passage une territoire du
savoir tellement du vécu au territoire
du savoir en quoi d'essence cela
interfère parce que je peux réparer
aussi de ce que j'appelle les knowledge
management et que vous connaissez
certainement eu connaissance extrêmement
important parce que nous avons encore
deux ans encore des jeunes aujourd'hui
je le dit plusieurs failles peut-être
que mes prédécesseurs pour en dire plus
sur ça c'est qu'il ya encore des gens
qui n'ont pas accès
différentes possibilités d'être devenir
et qui sont toujours bloqués quelques
parents s'installent chez eux et qui a
besoin justement de ce démarrage ce
fonds de secours des projets du
territoire mais n'ont pas de la manière
a dit hier que je vais venir investir et
je vais j'ai besoin d'argent parce que
le premier problème du premier parc de
sceaux faisant cela
de trouver l'argent donc c'est de
trouver du bab
c'est le trophée celui ou celle qui va
prendre cette initiative
il va travailler c'est pas l'argent qui
difficile à voir c'est comment faire
comment être ce savoir m mais c'est
aussi savoir vivre le montant de ces
sahraouis
aujourd'hui beaucoup de beaucoup de cet
esprit de recul par rapport à ce qu'on
est
quand j'ai dit tout à l'heure vous
gagnez j'ai entendu cette annonce était
non pas sa nomination n'est pas
responsable
l'objet m'ont pas fait je vous entendre
sursis pour port vila des montants trop
facile plus un peu importe mais
aujourd'hui il faut dépasser ses
contrastes dans quand je dirais donc bon
je fais un travail ou deux livres j'ai
rencontré ce genre de problème même avec
les etr il travaille justement les acras
de travail dans le territoire pour
réussir cette émergence vers la même
question eric thomas
ceci étant dit
la question que les acteurs très
importante qui fait croire dans les
électrodes qui fait quoi dans les airs
il n'y a pas que la société civile qui
est très importante qui joue un rôle
important
l'américaine est encore très d'effriter
et désorienté jeu télé et lui manque
encore un travail de collaboration nous
essaie de le 16e paradoxe le septième
celui de 2,30 à la version
l'individualisation de l'individualité
versus collectif
on va voir votre arme en traîneau
collectif et qu'on nous demande de
travailler ensemble
on vous dit non non on va pas être je
vais pas encore manger et même dans les
recherches
on a fait des matches un peu
d'expérience malgré son émergence faire
disparaître de recherche au monde dames
âgées souffrent toujours je suis
sûrement de manière très individuelle ne
termine pas tout
cet axe est justement la formation à la
recherche de près pas numérotées et donc
individuelle ou collective c'est aussi
très importante pour avancer dans la
parcelle de territoire il y en ad'autres
justement d'autres questions qui doivent
être
je vais discuter d'accord pour que
justement pour deux des patients c'est
le cas ce champ du fait le territoire
peut être m'en nous avons appris en
économie que il n'y a pas de territoire
qui j'ai le bonheur
y'a pas un territoire où il y alliant de
tout simplement je pourrais définir
maintenant puisqu'on a avancé le la
direction que le territoire était garé à
cet espace il y avait de la géographie
espace géographique et géologique plus
seul xxl nepad et forcément ça mais que
je peux changer sa part à certaines
tendances d'évolution qui existent tout
ce qui n'est pas je gravis biologiques
et physiologiques
il est humain dont le génie comique
c'est sous lui même c'est tout ce que
j'ai dit à leurs toits de cette
dynamique
ces ethnies qui on doit protéger contre
gare des combes et des vents mais pas
forcément comme une question qui fait de
nous le seul devant mais quand on doit
intégrer comme diversité tout simplement
pas ça c'est très important a souligné
diversité au centre culturel terme n'ont
pas de sens politique du terme puisque
j'ose dire au monde que le politique
dans le territoire du lac estion s'agit
là du mans est ce que vous savez que le
clivage droite gauche dans notre aussi
dans notre expérience pour montrer que
nous n'avons pas par des sources
policières
les partis de droite du parti que je
sens que je vais éviter le moment a
expliqué norman hier quand on voit le
territoire donc voilà un autre paradoxe
fondateur je dirais oui
l'affluence le territoire d'apporter
territoire c'est pour les divisions
gommer ou obligés de passer par la
police
voilà un article si vous voulez
l'évidence non voici quelques éléments
je dirais aux vapeurs de cette
expérience
la neige fait face quotidiennement dans
le travail en tant que cas mais aussi au
travail ne pouvait de futurs travaux de
recherche dans le maïs roulant je
voudrais juste dire que aujourd'hui nous
devions des écoles de recherche les
écoles les instituts et universités
doivent donner plus de temps plus de
temps c'est ce qu'elle sera brillant des
questions la bascule souvent aux fêtes
et stages dans différents établissements
différents territoires dépendante de ces
éléments moteurs je dirais pour
justement appréhender entre andré
fonctionnement puisque à la fois nous
sommes en train de réfléchir ensemble et
c'est justement l'objectif d'un teaser
nous ensemble et puis dans cette
réflexion d'ensemble pour rien justement
donné sans forcément se voir ce que
j'appelle des territoires du fun